FINALLY, WE CAN ALL AGREE
I'M A HUGE TV STAR.
AGREED?
AGREED.
WHICH IS WHY
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE FUN
TO BECOME A HUGE MOVIE STAR.
YOU KNOW, GET OUT OF MY COMFORT
ZONE, TRY NEW THINGS.
I'M NOT ASKING
TO BE A LEADING MAN,
DESPITE THE LEADING MAN LOOKS.
I'VE SEEN WHAT CAN HAPPEN
WHEN A COMEDY CENTRAL STAR
TRIES TO CARRY A FILM.
SORRY, DEMETRI.
GOOD LUCK, MS. SCHUMER.
I JUST WANT A BUNCH
OF TOSH CAMEOS.
I WOULD HAVE LOVED TO HAVE BEEN
IN JURASSIC WORLD THIS SUMMER.
YOU KNOW,
JUST SOME GUY WITH ICE CREAM,
AND A DINOSAUR EATS ME.
[CLAMORING AND CHATTER]
CAN YOU BELIEVE THEY'RE OUT
OF PISTACHIO ICE CREAM?
WHAT KIND OF THEME PARK IS THIS?
HAD TO GO WITH THAT ICE CREAM
THAT HAS BUBBLE GUM IN IT.
[DINOSAUR ROARING]
AHH!
"WAIT, WAS THAT DANIEL TOSH?
I'M PRETTY SURE
THAT WAS DANIEL TOSH."
THAT'S WHAT EVERYBODY
WILL BE SAYING.
THEN THEY'LL TELL
ALL THEIR FRIENDS.
BOOM. VIRAL.
SO LISTEN UP, HOLLYWOOD.
HERE ARE MY NONNEGOTIABLE TERMS
TO GET ME IN YOUR MOVIE.
FIRST, I ONLY WANT TO BE ON SET
FOR ONE DAY.
PREFERABLY, I'D LIKE TO WRAP
BEFORE LUNCH.
SECOND, MY RATE: $25,000,
WHICH NORMALLY,
I WOULDN'T GET OUT OF BED FOR.
IN RETURN FOR SAID FEE,
YOU WILL ENJOY
A CONSIDERABLE BOX OFFICE BUMP
THANKS TO ENDLESS FREE PROMOTION
ON COMEDY CENTRAL'S
FLAGSHIP SHOW,
NOT TO MENTION
MY SOCIAL MEDIA PRESENCE,
WHICH HAS BEEN RANKED AMONG
THE TOP 50 IN THE WORLD
BY FORBES.
(ALL)
OOH.
YEAH.
THIRD, I AM WILLING TO AUDITION,
BUT ONLY ON MY SHOW.
SEND ME THE SIDES,
I'M NOT READING THE SCRIPT,
LET ME KNOW WHO'S ATTACHED,
AND I'LL AIR MY AUDITION.
IF YOU LIKE WHAT YOU SEE
AND AGREE TO MY CONDITIONS,
WE CAN SHOOT A PICTURE.
ALL RIGHT.
HAVE A PLEASANT SUMMER.
BYE, FELICIA.